i i talk about epstein a lot so i'm like
oh you do yeah
and and he i was gonna say in terms of
conspiracy theory
that one changed my outlook because i
was like i was like whoa
like you have this dude who convinced
some of the most successful people on
earth that he
was like some money manager and it looks
like it was totally fake
like leon black i mean this is one of
the richest men on wall street
nine billion dollar net worth why has he
given him
over a hundred million dollars between
2015 and 2019.
yeah what's going on here lex wexner
same thing so yeah i want to hear
because
you know people who met him and the only
person i know who met him was eric
weinstein i've heard his
right oh boy so i listen i'm still
in and eric is fascinating and like eric
is full on
saying that he was a mossad or whatever
yeah there's a point for something uh
something
much much bigger um and there's uh
whatever his name robert maxwell all the
all those stories
like you could dig deeper and deeper
that jeffrey's just like
the tip of the iceberg i just think he's
an exceptionally charismatic
listen this isn't speaking from
confidence or like
deep understanding the situation but
from my
speaking with people he just seems like
at least from the side of his influence
and interaction with researchers he just
seems like somebody that was
exceptionally charismatic
and actually took interest
he was unable to speak about interesting
scientific things
but he took interest in them so he knew
how to stroke the egos of a lot of
powerful people like well
like in in different kinds of ways i
suppose
i don't know about this because i don't
have
like if a really okay this is this is
weird to say but
i have an ability okay i think
women are beautiful i like women but
like if if like a supermodel
came to me or something like like i'm
able to reason it seems like some people
yes are not able to think clearly when
there's like an attractive woman in the
room
and i think that was one of the tools he
used
to manipulate people interesting i don't
know
listen it's like the pedophile thing
right i don't know how many people are
complete sex addicts but like it seems
like
like looking out into the world like
there's like the metoo movement have
revealed that there's a lot of like
weird yeah
like uh creepy people out there i don't
know
but i think it was just one of the many
tools that he used
uh to convince people and manipulate
people but not in some like um
evil way but more just really good
at the art of conversation and just
winning people over on the side and then
by building through that process
building a network of other really
powerful people
and not explicitly but
implicitly having done shady [ __ ]
with powerful people yeah like building
up a kind of
implied power of like
like we did some shady [ __ ] together
so we're not like you're going to help
me out on this extra thing i need to
know and that builds and builds and
builds to where you're able to actually
control like have quite a lot of power
without
explicitly having like a strategy
meeting
and i think a single person or
yeah i think a single person can do that
it can start that ball rolling
and over time it becomes a group thing
like i don't know if
uh julian maxwell was involved or others
and yeah over time it becomes almost
like a really powerful organization
that wasn't that's not a front for
something
much deeper and bigger but it's almost
like maybe it's because i love cellular
automata man
a system that starts out as a simple
thing with simple rules
can create incredible complexity yes and
so i just think that
uh we're now looking in retrospect it
looks like an incredibly complex system
that's operating in
but like that's just because it's you
know there could be a lot of other
jeffrey epstein's
in in my perspective that this simple
thing just
uh was successful early on it builds and
builds and builds and builds
and then there's uh creepy [ __ ] that
like a lot of aspects of the system
helped it get bigger and bigger and more
powerful and so on
so the final result is i mean
listen i have a pretty optimistic i have
a
i tend to see the good in people and so
it's been heartbreaking to me in general
just to see
you know people i look up to not have
the level of integrity i thought they
would
or like the strength of character all
those kinds of things
and it seems like you should be able to
to see the [ __ ] that is jeffrey
epstein like when you meet him
right uh we're not talking about like
eric weinstein like one or two or three
or five interactions
but like there's people that had like
like years of relationship with him yeah
and i don't know i i'm not sure even
after he was convicted
after his conviction yeah there's
there's stories i mean i don't need to
sort of uh i honestly believe
okay here's the open question i have i
don't
know how many creepy sexual people that
are out there
like i don't know if there is like
like the people i know the faculty and
so on
i don't know if they have like a kink
that i'm just not aware of that was
being
leveraged because to me it seems like
if if if people aren't if not
everybody's a pedophile
[Laughter]
then it's just the art of conversation
that is just like the art of just like
manipulating people by making them feel
good about like the exciting stuff
they're doing listen man academics are
people talk about money
i don't think academics care about money
as much as people think
what they care about is like somebody
they they want to be uh it's the same
thing that instagram models
post in their butt pictures is they want
to be loved
they want attention my parents are
professors
[Laughter]
they they and jeff epstein like the
money
is another way to show attention right
it's my work matters and and and he
for some of he did that for some of the
weirdest most brilliant people i don't
want to sort of
drop names but everybody knows them it's
like people that are
the most interesting academics is the
one he cared about
like people are thinking about the most
difficult questions
of in all of science and all of
engineering so those people
are we're kind of outcasts in academia a
little bit because they're doing the
weird [ __ ] they're the weirdos
and he cared about the weirdos and he
gave them money and that
uh you know i that's i don't know if
there's something more nefarious than
that
i i hope not but maybe i'm surprised and
in fact
half the population of the world is
pedophiles no i i think it's what you
were talking about which is that
it's the it's the implication
after the initial right like you do some
shady things together or you do
something that you want out of the
public eye and you're a public person
and look we probably even experienced
this to a limited extent right you're
like ah
you know like i don't want to i don't
almost lost my temper you know one time
whenever a car hit me and i'm like i
can't freak out in public anymore
that you know like what if somebody
takes a photo or something yeah and so
i think that there's an extent to that
times a billion
literally when you have a billion
dollars or more and you take that all
together and you stack it up on itself
i saw a story about like bill clinton
like bill clinton was with epstein
or with gelane maxwell in a private air
terminal or something
and she had one of their like sex you
know
one of those girls who was underage had
her dressed up in a literal like pilot
uniform
and she was underage in order to you
know and she was just
being disguised for being older and she
was a masseuse
right because that was one of the uh
guys's which they got in order to
sexually traffic these women
and she was like bill was like
complaining about his neck and she's
like give bill clinton a
massage right so now there's a photo of
an underage girl giving a massage
to the former president of the united
states i don't think he knew
right but like that looks bad and so
this is kind of what we're getting at
which is that you're setting it all up
and creating those preconditions
or like prince andrew do i think prince
andrew knew that virginia gouffrey
was underage i don't know probably knew
she was pretty young
which i think is you know skeevy enough
where you're a [ __ ] prince you
probably know better yeah
but i don't think he knew she was
underage or maybe he did and if he did
and he's even
more of a piece of [ __ ] than i thought
but we when we when we look at these
things
the the stuff i'm more interested in is
like what you were talking about i'm
like bill gates
how do you get the richest man in the
world in your house
yeah like under what guy and gates is
like he was talking about financing and
all this i'm like
you don't have access to money or
bankers like
you're the richest man in the world like
you can call goldman sachs anytime you
want on a hotline like
why do you need that's where that's
where i start again to get more
conspiratorial because i'm like
bill dude you can you have the gold
credit right
like you don't need epstein to create
some complicated financing structure
or leon black like what is
2015 2009 i mean this is very recent
stuff
or and this is the part that really got
me as i read the depart
i think it's called the department of
financial services report around
deutsche bank
with epstein the news a criminal
they solicited his business explicitly
knew
that his business meant access to other
high net worth individuals
consistently doled money out from his
account for hush payments
to women in europe and prostitution
rings they knew all of this
within the bank it was elevated multiple
times
here was the other one one of epstein's
associates was like hey how much money
can we take out before we hit the
you know automatic sensor before you
have to tell the irs
and that question by by their own
standards is supposed to result
in a notification to the feds and they
never did it and he was withdrawing like
two million dollars of cash
in five years for tips yeah i'm like
okay
like something's going on here you see
what i'm saying there's a lot of
signs that make you think that there is
a bigger thing at play
than just the man that there is some
it does look like a larger organization
is using this
front right it's again i don't know i i
truly don't know and i'm not willing to
use the certainty which i think a lot of
people online are to say like it
one hundred yes the certainty you know
that's always the problem because that
that's probably
why i hesitate to touch conspiracy
theories is because i'm allergic to
certainty in all forms
in politics any kind of discourse and
people are so
sure in both directions actually it's
it's kind of hilarious uh
either they're sure that the conspiracy
theory
a particular whatever the conspiracy
theories is false like
they almost dismiss it like uh like
they don't even want to talk about it's
like the people like the way they
dismiss
that the earth is flat yes most
scientists are like
they don't even want to like hear
what the what the flat earthers are
saying they don't have
like zero patience for it which is like
maybe in that case yeah it's deserved
but everything else
you really like have empathy like
consider the f you have okay this is
weird to say but
i feel like you have to
consider that the earth might be flat
for like
one minute like you have to be
empathetic you have to be open-minded
you